القت الحرب التي تشنها اسرائيل على قطاع
غزه للشهر الثالث على التوالي بظلالها على
اجواء احتفالات عيد الميلاد في مدينه بيت
لحم في الضفه الغربيه فاجء هذه السنه
اختلفت عن المعتاد اعتادت مدينه بيت لحم
ان ترتدي زينتها سنويا وتمتلئ باضواء
الاحتفالات فتزين شجره عيد الميلاد ساحه
المهدي وسط حشود من السياح الاجانب الذين
يتجمعون كل عام للاحتفال الا ان هذه السنه
كانت مختلفه فلم تعزف فرق الكشافه لدى
دخول بطريرك اللاتين ساحه الكنيسه واضت
الشموع واقيمت الصلوات فقط في ساحه كنيسه
المهد بحضور عدد من رجال الدين
والمسؤولين بدلا من اضاءه شجره عيد
الميلاد التي اعتادت بيت لحم وضعها بعلو
ثانيه امتار وضع مجسم لحجم الدمار الذي
لحق بالقطاع ويم ثل المجسم الذي نفذه
الفنان الفلسطيني طارق سلسع مغاره الميلاد
وسط ما بدا انه منزل مدمر كما نرى هنا
واطلق عليه اسم الميلاد تحت الانقاض في
اشاره رمزيه للدمار اضافه الى تماثيل
لعائله فلسطينيه اثناء النكبه في
الفاتيكان تراس البابا فرانسيس قداس عيد
الميلاد للروم الكاثوليك وتحدث عن الصراع
في الاراضي المقدسه بالقول قلبنا الليله
في بيت لحم حيث لا يزال امير السلام يتعرض
للرفض من قبل منطق الحرب الخاسر ومع هدير
الاسلحه الذي يمنعه اليوم ايضا من ان يكون
له موضع في العالم اذا سنستعرض معكم بعض
من تعليقاتكم على اجواء العيد في فلسطين
نبداها هنا
برامز اذا يقول رامز مهد السيد المسيح
حزين لاول مره بتاريخ فلسطين كيف ممكن ان
نحتفل كمسيحيين بعيد الميلاد والبلد التي
ولد فيها يسوع المسيح تتعرض للتدمير
ويتعرض شعبها للاباده كلنا كمسيحيين حزنون
على ما يجري ننتقل معكم الى هنا هنا تقول
هنا هم كذلك يتعرضون للتنكيل والطرد من
بيوتهم في القدس والضفه وتهديم الكنائس
والمعابد وقصفوا في غزه واعدمت امراه
وابنتها في غزه عدو يحارب السلام وكل ما
هو جميل على الارض نصل الى حساب سيمو يقول
م قف شجاع ويقوي اواصر الترابط بين مكونات
الشعب الفلسطيني بكافه اطيافه نتمنى ان
توحد كلمه السياسيين كذلك لجميع الفصائل
في سبيل مقاومه الاحتلال وقمعه المستمر في
الضفه قبل القطاع اخيرا نصل الى رندا رندا
تقول هنا غزه بوصت اخلاق العالم لا فرح في
قلوبنا مادام اخواننا في غزه تحت القصف
اعلموا جيدا اننا بقلب واحد وشعب واحد اما
في غزه اما في غزه حيث يعيش حوالي 1100
شخص من الديانه المسيحيه لجا العديد منهم
الى كنيسه القديس ريفيوس بحي الزيتون
شمالي قطاع غزه وعشيه عيد الميلاد انزل
سلاح الجو الاردني الاحد مظلات انسانيه
لمئات المحاصرين في الكنيسه الموجوده في
حي الزيتون وفق ما اعلن الجيش في بيان
وبحسب المصدر يقدر عدد المحاصرين بالكنيسه
بنحو 800 مواطن يعانون من شحن في الطعام
ونقص حاد في مستلزمات الحياه الاساسيه